♫ Na na na na Na na na na
♫ Leave the light on Leave the light on
♫ Na na na na Na na na na ♫
(cell phone ringing)
- What's up, fuck stick?
- Yo!
- The last thing she texted was,
"See you tonight, heart, heart."
- [Guy with Glasses] What?
Dude, she's totally down.
- Yeah, I know she's down
but is she like (sucking)
whip cream, bikini down?
- [Guy in Glasses] It's weird
that you're so in to that.
- So, first wrapped, talked
for a long time down?
- I don't know, probably in the middle.
- So, maybe whip cream one-piece down?
- How many dates have you guys been on?
- I don't know like...
(slaps loudly)
Whoa!
Did you see that?
- [Guy in Glasses] What?
- [Guy in Glasses] What happened?
- Dude, there's somebody
in my fucking shower, man!
What the fuck was that? It's huge!
- [Guy in Glasses] I don't
know, I didn't see anything.
- I don't know, man, there's
something in my shower.
(doorbell rings)
Oh, shit! Lily's here.
Oh, fuck!
(scary music)
(door squeaking)
♫ Leave the light on
♫ Na na na na Na na na ♫